[Music]
thank you
one of the key plot points that's in the
background actually not really known
about at all until it's revealed in
chapter 12 of Philip K Dick's novel a
man in the High Castle is what they call
operation dandelion and it's got a
rather innocuous name but it's the title
for a plot or rather grand plan a grand
strategy plan for the Nazis to dominate
The Globe currently in the story we have
three main Axis powers that have won
World War II and now it's decades later
we have the German Reich we have the
Japanese empire and then we have the
very much smaller and weaker Italian
Empire which is largely aligned with the
the Reich and the Reich is in many
respects more powerful than the Japanese
empire
Prosperity sphere and they also have
this constant expansionist tendency this
need that has been noted earlier in the
novel through the eyes and you know the
words and thoughts of several characters
to always transgress to go beyond to
launch themselves into bigger and bigger
projects and what could be a bigger
project than complete global domination
and so what we find out is there's a
meeting that's been arranged between two
high-level officials and one of which is
you know very high former retired
General
um in in the Japanese empire and then we
have the opvair operative Rudolph Wegner
who has been posing as a Swedish
businessman and Mr tagumi has organized
this in order to provide them with a
sort of of cover so first the general
shows up and they you know offer him tea
and he doesn't doesn't want to take it
and then he um tagomi says this Mr bines
who I've met and entertained in my home
declares himself a Swede yet perusal
persuades one he is in fact a highly
placed German of some sort
and then he says uh his agitation
concerning this meeting causes me to
infer a connection with the political
upheavals in the Reich and the general
says Ah you're fishing not actually
informing me and then uh Baines comes in
and introduces himself he says sir I am
captain R Wegner of the reich's naval
counterintelligence that's what op fair
is as understood I represent no one but
myself in certain private unnamed
individuals no departments or bureaus of
the right government of any sort the
general then responds hair vedner I
understand that you in no way officially
allege representation of any branch of
the right government I am here as an
unofficial private party who by virtue
of former position with the Imperial
Army can be said to have access to
circles in Tokyo who desire to hear
whatever you have to say and tagomi says
to himself we are discourse but not
unpleasant certain near musical quality
to it refreshing relief in fact and so
this is all the setup for the exchange
of information and the decision that now
is going to have to be made
so Bain says without Preamble I would
like to inform you and those who have
access you have access to that there is
in advance stage in the Reich a program
called
Luzon dandelion yes the general said
nodding as if you'd heard this before
but Mr tagomi said he seemed quite eager
for Banes to go on so what is Operation
dandelion well it's essentially got
three parts to it the first part he says
Baines says dandelion consists of an
incident on the border of the Rocky
Mountain States and the United States
U.S troops will be attacked and will
retaliate by crossing the border and
engaging the regular Rocky Mountain
States troop station nearby the U.S
troops have detailed maps showing
Midwest Army installations this is step
one step two consists of the Declaration
of Germany regarding the conflict of
volunteer Detachment of Vermont
paratroopers will be sent to the the U.S
however this is further camouflage so
what we've got is what we nowadays call
a false flag operation kind of similar
to what the Nazis did to enable them to
invade Poland right so it's not
unprecedented in fact you could say it's
a Nazi old ruse an Mo that they're going
to be doing so that's the first part and
it's creating a distraction
the second part is where the knockout
punch comes
so he says the basic purpose of
operation dandelion is an enormous
nuclear attack on the home Islands
without Advance warning of any kind
and tadaki says with the purpose of
wiping out Royal Family Home Defense
Army most of Imperial Navy civil
population
Industries resources leaving overseas
possession for absorption by the Reich
and so that would be the third part this
absorption of all of the Japanese
Holdings outside of Japan itself
being absorbed by the Third Reich which
then would have global domination so
this is some pretty incredible horrific
evil that is being planned out not just
for members of the Japanese
co-prosperity sphere or the Japanese
Elite but really worldwide because the
Japanese they're not great but at least
from we could say ethical perspectives
they're not terrible either whereas the
Reich clearly is
so then this leads to a issue
when is it supposed to happen and uh you
know Bain says well things have been
moved up at least I presume I'm not in
contact with the op Fair now and then he
says you need to think about the reich's
factions he says we recommend the
Japanese government enter into the
reich's domestic situation or at least
that was what I came here to recommend
certain groups in the Reich favor
operation dandelion other certain others
do not it was hoped that those opposing
it would come to power upon the death of
Chancellor Borman but it doesn't look
like that's going to be the case and so
the general says okay who's for who's
against
well goobbels who is going to take power
as we're going to see uh gibbles is an
advocate of dandelion and then tadaki
says who stands opposed SS General
heydrich
and he says I'm taken by surprise is
this legitimate information or only a
Viewpoint which you and your colleagues
holding says well let me spell it out
for you administration of the East the
area held by Japan would be the foreign
office rosenberg's people this was a
bitterly disputed issue in many sessions
between the principles last year I have
photo stats of the notes taken the
police demanded Authority but were
turned down there to manage space
colonization that's going to be their
domain once this division of authority
was settled the police put all their
weight behind the space program and
against dandelion so heydrich is is not
actually opposed because he's got you
know moral problems with it as We Know
he's actually pretty terrible but
because he wasn't going to get uh part
of the the spoils
and so tadaki says rivalry one group
played against another by the leader so
he's never challenged and then Bane says
so that's why I'm here I'm I'm to plead
for your intervention it is still
possible to intervene the situation is
still fluid it'll be months before Dr
gubbles can consolidate his position
he'll have to break the police possibly
have hadrik and other top SS and SD
leaders executed once that's done and
then now we get to thinking about well
what is this going to entail intervening
in the reich's domestic situation
it involves supporting people in order
to prevent an evil
supporting people that you know are evil
to the very core
and so tadaki says the emperor would
never tolerate this policy he regards
the reichs elite corpse wherever the
black uniform is worn the death head the
castle system all to him is evil
and here we get to gomi uh reflecting on
this saying evil Mr tagumi thought yes
it is are we to assist it in gaining
power in order to save our lives is that
the Paradox of our Earthly situation and
then tagomi says I cannot face this
dilemma the the man should have to act
in such moral ambiguity there is no way
capital W no doubt right no place to go
in this all is muddled uh a chaos of
light and dark and
um
is going to be saying listen the SD the
secret Deen's height the people that
under heydrich they are the most
malignant part of the Nazi regime German
Society we're supposed to support these
horrible people and uh Barnes goes on
and says the moral practices of the
black shirts exceed in ferocity that of
the Vermont the the regular army but
their power is less
we should reflect solely on reality on
actual power not on ethical intentions
and then notice to gomi who's just
brought up this you know Paradox and
muddle says yes we must be realists so
if they're going to do this they have to
make a decision that they're going to
put aside ethical considerations normal
ethical considerations to support a part
of the Nazi regime taking power which is
very very evil in many many respects
right malignant ferocious are the words
used to describe them
precisely to keep operation dandelion
from happening
and so they start thinking about the ins
and outs of how this is going to work
how they can actually reach heydrich and
uh
um you know Banes or or uh you know the
Spy Wagner actually says listen we're
not going to get to him through the uh
Opera they've been trying to eliminate
us for a long time the you know entire
faction hates our guts
um maybe somebody else how are we going
to reach this heydrich faction so that
is that is a a significant problem and
then what we see ending up happening in
the very end of the work is that
um Wagner goes back to Germany he gets
arrested at the airport and it's
actually the SD men who take him in and
he finds out that uh heydrich is with
sept Dietrich at the okw of the late
standard division you know there's going
to be a rift now between the Vermont the
Army and the SD and the SS that are
being run here and it looks like gerbils
is actually losing the power that he has
maybe the Google's government will fall
after all uh Wagner thought as he was
ushered into the waiting staff sedan and
he says but what does it matter and this
is a really key idea here even if Dr
gibbles is deposed in operation
dandelion is canceled
they will still exist the black shirts
the parte the schemes if not in the
orient and somewhere else on Mars and
Venus
and he thinks to himself no wonder Mr
tagomi could not go on now Mr tagomi we
should mention had to shoot with his
antique pistol two SD men and was having
a rather rough time with the fact that
he in order to save one life he had to
destroy too
no wonder Mr tagomi could not go on the
terrible dilemma of our lives whatever
happens it is evil Beyond Compare why
struggle then why choose if the
alternatives are the same
evidently we go on as we always have
from day to day at this moment we work
against operation dandelion later at
another moment we work to defeat the
police but we cannot do it all at once
it is a sequence an unfolding process we
can only control the end by making a
choice
at each step and this is the problematic
situation of ethical action not actually
two sides to it one is that you cannot
engage in ethical action within a
universe that is as screwed up as it is
without collaborating with without
fostering without permitting some evil
yourself in order to prevent evil in
order to combat evil right so that could
be very demoralizing and then the other
part that's demoralizing you can't do it
all at once there are no
Perfect Solutions
there is no way to snap your fingers and
have good realized automatically because
of that and then he thinks to himself we
can only hope and try on some other
world possibly it is different better
there are clear good and evil
Alternatives not these obscured mixtures
these blends with no proper tool by
which to untangle the components we do
not have the ideal World such as we
would like where morality is easy
because cognition is easy where one can
do right with no effort because he can
detect the obvious in a world an
alternate you know history in which the
Axis powers one there isn't any easy
solutions like that it's picking between
greater and lesser evils and using
Prudence to do that so what they've
decided is that at least you know to go
me the the
General
Wagner all the people that they're
representing
resisting operation dandelion which
would be a destruction of the entire
Japanese society and power base and
absorption by the right that is the
greater evil
that has to be resisted by collaborating
with human beings and entire you know
associations and societies that are
themselves thoroughly in many complex
ways evil as well so it seems like you
you have to take evil in one way or
another but that's part of how you also
resist evil at least in this world that
dick has sketched out for us